salut aujourd'hui c'est la journée du
masters classes ça va pas être un master
class trop long par rapport aux autres
semaines parce qu'il vient en complément
d'un autre masters classes tout prend
son sens maintenant je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui du palais mental alors
pourquoi c'est en lien avec autre chose
parce que le premier master class que je
vous ai fait était basée sur la mémoire
sur la table de rappel les techniques de
table de rappel c'était la vidéo 37 du
27 février je pense que depuis le 27
février vous avez eu le temps de
travailler votre table de rappel et donc
il est temps de parler du palais mentale
le palais mentale qu'est ce que c'est
excellent de questions merci de l'avoir
posée c'est un lieu imaginaire que vous
avez créés dans votre tête vous allez
pouvoir déposer des informations et à
chaque fois vous allez retourner dans ce
lieu les informations bon vous revenir à
l'esprit telles que vous les aviez
laissées au préalable souvenez vous je
vous avais expliqué que le cerveau aime
beaucoup les images aime beaucoup
d'imaginaire bien c'est pour ça que le
palais mentale marche bien le premier
palais mental qu'on peut se construire
assez facilement c'est de prendre un
lieu qu'on connaît déjà très bien qu'on
connaît par coeur souligne notre enfant
soit un lieu actuel d'aujourd'hui et
c'est pas forcément un grand lieu ça
peut être une seule pièce par exemple
mon premier palet mental c'était ma
chambre où j'habitais chez mes parents
j'imaginais faire le tour de ma chambre
point par point de la porte où je
faisais tout autour de la chambre je
ressortais et ça me faisait avaler
mentale complet car le palais mentale
doit toujours être associé à un trajet
on y reviendra un petit peu plus tard
dans la vidéo choisie c'est donc un
endroit que vous connaissez très bien
parker en détail un endroit réel donc
dont vous visualisez toutes les parties
assez facilement 7 pas obligé de le
faire maintenant maintenant non plus
quand c'est le principe du master class
vous pouvez le travail et après avoir vu
la vidéo dans la semaine
dans la vidéo numéro 34 vous expliquer
comment ça vous souvenir de n'importe
quel numéro de téléphone le palais
mentale permet ça aussi et permet encore
plus si on associe à deux techniques
maintenant que vous avez un lyon en tête
vous allez devoir déterminer un trajet
et sur ce trajet on va identifier des
spots les spots ça va être les endroits
où vous allez pouvoir déposer
mentalement quelque chose je garde
l'exemple de ma chambre
oui ça c'est pas un bureau d'adolescents
enfin contrairement aux apparences il ya
quand même un drone et j'ai oublié de
grandir vous pouvez identifier autant de
spots que vous voulez 5 c'est bien pour
commencer dit ça ça commençait à être un
petit peu cool et après ça peut être 20
ça peut être 30 ça peut être les
l'infini donc dans ma chambre
j'imagine un spot ça va être au niveau
de la porte après il y avait
bibliothèque qui avait sur sur ma gauche
donc en passant le long de ce mur je
peux imaginer la bibliothèque et puis en
face il y avait le bureau et la fenêtre
comme fer de spock le bureau et la
fenêtre
et puis après je vais sur la droite y
avait des étagères et puis encore sur la
droite il y avait un lit et puis encore
à côté il y avait eu notre armoire voilà
un exemple de spots que je peux
identifier dans votre palais mentale à
vous dans votre lieu vous identifier des
endroits où vous pouvez faire un trajet
virtuelle dans votre tête c'est matrix 1
là dedans où vous pourrez déposer vos
informations au tac pour vous servir
ensuite de cet endroit magique et
imaginaire vous avez de technique de
dépôt le dépôt simple et le dépôt
complexe je vous confesse que je ne sais
pas si ça se dit comme ça où ça a été
identifié comme ça c'est mon jargon le
dépôt simple ça consiste à mettre de
vraies informations qui existent
réellement sans les transformer dans les
zones de dépôts exemple concret si je
dois aller faire des courses et acheté
une dizaine de choses et que je veux
juste les mémoriser très rapidement sans
aucun effort
je me baladais dans mon palais mentale
et à chacun des spots je vais mettre la
chose que je dois acheter il s'agit pas
de mémoriser il s'agit de créer un
imaginaire concret si je dois acheter un
pack de lait alors j'ouvre la porte de
la chambre
dans le palais que j'ai pris un exemple
et j'accroche une bouteille de lait à la
poigne et quand je dis je la croche
c'est vraiment dans ma tête j'imagine à
la poignée que une bouteille de lait qui
a accroché
et puis je vais déposer dans l'armoire
un autre objet à la fenêtre sur le
bureau sur les étagères sur le lit
encore sur l'autre armoire je vais
imaginer la présence de ces objets dans
ses spots là donc c'est un dépôt simple
puisque je prends une information qui
existent je prends l'imagerie d'un sac
de tomates je dépose les tomates sur le
lit j'ai un peu buggé parce que je
dépose pas vraiment les tomates sur le
lit je vais vous dire je les éclater sur
mon lit mentale en fait il est tout à
fait de tomates puisque plus
l'information est riche comme ça et un
petit peu particulière
mieux je vais le retenir aucun autre
effort de mémoire à faire si ce n'est
que quand j'irai dans le magasin je vais
me re malade est dans mon palais mental
de spot en spot et les objets que j'
avais déposé vont me revenir à la
mémoire immédiatement instantanément
c'est magique mais qu'en est il du dépôt
complexe
exemple concret la suit je fais trop mal
le super héros le dépôt complexe et le
fait de l'associer à une autre technique
et là ça devient très intéressant 6
utilise la technique de la table de
rappel qui me permet de coder des
nombres
en images ça veut dire que je gagne en
puissance dans ce que je vais pouvoir
mettre dans mes zones de dépôts je vais
pouvoir déposer des choses qui sont
abstraites comme les nombres et les
chiffres mon compte bancaire si je le
connais par coeur je le déposer dans mon
palais mental je vais le découper au
préalable par nombre de deux je vais
transformer chacun de ces nombres en
images via ma table de rappel que je
connais déjà par coeur puisque je la
travaille depuis début février
et ce sont ces images là que je vais
déposer dans les spots lors de mon
trajet ce qui fait que quand j'aurai
besoin de mon numéro de compte j'irai
dans ma tête dans mon palais mental je
me déplacerai de spot en spot je verrai
les images que je vais immédiatement
retransformé en nombre et en chiffres
puisque je maîtrise ma table de rappel
comme un réflexe automatique et je serai
capable de réciter mon numéro de compte
sans même avoir à chercher à le retenir
concrètement le même manière vous pouvez
imaginer des techniques qui permettent
de retenir des mots pour apprendre par
exemple les verbes irréguliers en
anglais pour apprendre les étapes clés
d'un discours pour apprendre tout ce que
vous voulez au final
d'ailleurs dans l'une des vidéos de la
semaine prochaine je vous apprendrai à
retenir des mots dans une nouvelle
langue et vous pourrez vous servir du
palais mental pour les ranger les
stocker stockées dans votre tête
si vous utilisez cette technique
évidemment les numéros de téléphone
deviennent très simple à retenir à la
volée à la volée ça veut dire qu'après
il faut les mettre ailleurs pour
décharger le palais mental sinon la
meilleure technique serré celle que je
vous ai appris le 3 février pour les
numéros de téléphone pas technique que
vous avez j'espère associé également la
table de rappel vous êtes en train de
devenir des bêtes de mémoire là les amis
et enfin le palais imaginaire c'est un
peu comme la table de rappel vous pouvez
vous devez même en créer plusieurs
commencer par un seul évidemment mais
vous pouvez en créer des petits des
simples comme des pièces comme tout ce
que je vous disais ou alors des trajets
très simples comme me lever de mon lit
jusqu'à la salle de bains donc là ça
couvre plusieurs pièces qui en pleine
zone de dépôt possible vous pouvez donc
et devait donc en créer plusieurs ça va
vous servir dans certaines circonstances
il est intéressant par exemple d'avoir
quelques pièces avec cinq zones de dépôt
pour justement mettre des numéros de
téléphone rapidement à la volée sans
qu'on ait forcément le temps de
construire tout l'imaginaire pour une
histoire comme dans la technique vous
pourrez évidemment avoir un palais
imaginaire beaucoup plus complexe sur
toute une maison par exemple depuis tout
à l'heure je parle d' endroit fermé mais
attention un palais mental ça peut être
aussi en extérieur ça peut être soulevée
dans les airs et après pour les plus
petits qu d'entre vous vous pouvez créer
votre palais imaginaire vous pouvez
l'inventer de toutes pièces le créé de
toute pièce moi j'ai un palais
imaginaire il est assez peu fourni en
fait en réalité je vais vous le décrire
vous ne prenez pas pour un fou il ya un
an
à son rang c'est une pièce toute blanche
il ya des fenêtres mais depuis les
fenêtres je peux voir ce que je veux en
fait dépenser pas toujours le même
paysage ça c'est une technique que j'ai
appliqué ici et il ya beaucoup d'états
géants des grands casiers métalliques
avec des tiroirs qui sont numérotées
dans ses tiroirs geroge des choses
par exemple j'ai un quasi métallique où
je range tous les codes de portes
d'endroits que je souhaite retenir
alors ça c'est un désavantage c'est à
dire que si je range pas dans le palais
mental un code je peux le demandent et
20 fois à la personne en allant 20 fois
chez elle dans en un mois je leur
tiendrai pas j'ai tellement pris
l'habitude de stocker les choses que si
je le fais pas en fait je fais plus je
pourrai plus assez attention vous pouvez
donc essayer de construire votre propre
palais ça vraiment je vous le recommande
pour plus tard dans le temps ça se fait
étape par étape faut souvent s'y balader
même si on a rien à retenir pour un peu
regarder ce qu'il ya et faire en sorte
qu'ils tombent jamais en ruinant fête
tombe dans les oubliettes de la mémoire
c'est vachement beau ce que je dis
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
à commenter à me dire qu'elle valait
vous allez prendre pour commencer ou si
vous en avez déjà lequel sait quelle
technique aussi vous utilisez on peut
discuter dans les commentaires ça c'est
chouette n'oubliez pas de mettre un
petit pouce en l'air sur le youtube
comme ça je leur en serai dans mon
palais à moi dans mon palais à pouss
partager également la vidéo ça peut
intéresser des gens ça peut les aider en
tout cas je crois que ce savoir doit
circuler abonnez vous pourquoi n'êtes
pas encore abonné c'est pas la première
vidéo que vous regardez vous n'êtes pas
encore abonné abonnez-vous à la chaîne
voilà là c'est en train d'apparaître
vous pouvez aussi d'ailleurs venir me
voir en spectacle aux hallucinations
collectives et rendez vous demain matin
à 11 heures pour une explication sur le
mental vlog ciao